ça commence les yvelines frondeurs
cinéma neuvième édition c'est chaque
année un plaisir de vous inviter à venir
au cinéma dans un lieu sympathique de
votre commune
ce soir là c'est le cadre agréable du
château de plaisir qui accueille sept
séances en plein air masques distribués
à l'entrée gel hydroalcoolique à
disposition et chaise longue équipée de
housses pour respecter les mesures
sanitaires les yvelines ne font leur
cinéma n'ont pas souffert ce mardi 18
août de la concurrence de la demi finale
de ligue des champions du paris saint
germain et 250 personnes sont venues
voir le film d'animation tous en scène
petite curiosité de voir comment ça se
passe et le cinéma en plein air et puis
l'occasion de se retrouver entre entre
amis c'était une nouvelle expérience
c'était un film que j'avais pas vu non
plus donc une pierre deux coups car en
plein air on essaie - fermez donc un peu
moins de risque en général les yvelines
font leur cinéma ce sont pour cette
neuvième édition 40 séances en plein air
qui vont animer l'été dans le
département une programmation variée
films d'animation ou pour chanter
comédie ou encore blockbusters il y en a
pour tous les goûts des petits et aux
grands
ça m'a bien du cinéma je me croirais et
aux parades y est j'ai la visite des mes
petits enfants à la maison et j'étais
très contente de voir ce planeur cinéma
parce que je voulais faire plaisir avant
qu'il par une bande geste quelque chose
qu'il est craquante après l'enfer après
à l'époque où
où il n'y a pas beaucoup de salles de
cinéma en tunisie
elle nous amène des films en plein air
comme ça pour attirer le monde pour
qu'ils connaissent le monde de teens et
ça pour moi ça me fait rappeler mon
enfance et les séances sont ouvertes à
tous et gratuites elles commencent à
chaque fois à la nuit tombée vers 21h
l'opération se poursuit jusqu'au 8
septembre de quoi rêver encore au rythme
du septième art